you see a lot of girls who are well
behaved they're at home but then you
have the boys out here in the streets
smoking weed having girlfriends so again
we're talking about honor but we are
maybe as men blameworthy sometimes that
our daughters are going and falling into
Haram because we've made
we say men and women are different
absolutely yeah don't you think that it
should be applied differently if we are
different of course we should advise our
daughters Etc but are we doing anything
for our sons I genuinely believe I don't
think we're doing anything right so for
instance you see sometimes some mothers
or fathers walking out with their
children and the daughter is covered
from head to toe in Abaya and you know
and hijab and the boys wearing shorts
and he's wearing dressed Ali said the
emphasis has to be the same because the
punishment is the same in the grave it's
no different and I think that the root
of the problem is is not the the red
pill or the gender or the education is
our lack of Islamic knowledge red pill
is full of degenerate men they dishonor
women they are not masculine men I think
this is you don't think it's just me I'm
the only one nope you're doing that
brother just no there's somebody else
probably doing that to your future wife
and when the day comes and you're
marrying and you're like why did that
happen because she came across a man
like you so in Islam modesty is not just
looks modesty is your tongue yeah you
speak your heart the way you act your
character so it's an umbrella it's not
just Beauty and I genuinely believe that
men and women should be taught slightly
different things as they're growing up
to to conquer different battles that
they're going to face in life and and
also and also you know I find really
funny about the red pill they're very
funny they complain about yeah women
with their body guys body count and they
are the ones who of course
no
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Sada khajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and a shot of the regular award
click the link and donate what you can
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah welcome to another episode of
The Bitter truth show inshallah we took
a bit of a break but yeah today's topic
is actually something that I am very
very passionate about and I'm sure many
of the speakers the guests here as well
are
um before I start when praise Allah the
most merciful the most trust or Praises
glory and gratitude belong to him I want
to thank every single honorable guest
that's here today uh from the brothers
and the sister side inshallah and I'm
not going to waste any time I'm gonna
get straight into it you guys know the
rules if you don't know the rules bitter
buzzer if you disagree with the sister
the sisters disagree with the sisters or
vice versa press the buzzer you have one
and a half minutes where nobody can
interrupt you have your say you can only
press it once inshallah
um and just simple rules less abstain
from back biting slandering photo we
don't need to do that anyways we know
that and that's it so today's Topic in a
nutshell is um
why is there a greater emphasis when it
comes to modesty expectations
um or just like a specific way of life
when it comes to
sisters so for example you have
households where and I've seen this I
come from Japanese I come from you know
not being a Muslim I see it in my family
as well where now the tide has kind of
shifted a bit where the man the boy is
he's he's fine he can go have a
girlfriend
you can go mess around he can go
clubbing he can and he can do whatever
he likes but when it comes to the girl
it's no and this can be cultural but
does this have any place in Islam so the
discussion at hand is why is there a
greater emphasis on sisters as if like
Islam was only sent down to how a sister
should be modest is Modesty just for a
woman so just
have you ever come across this
um and why do we have this because
there's Muslim this is not Islam
um yeah so for me the way I see it is
we have like a culture in in the UK or
the west where we've normalized certain
practices and I think with the red pill
ideology you have a lot of again
emphasis on you know women are the cause
of the downfall of of men and boys and
women are the reason why
um you know things are not going very
well in in the household or you know
they are the cause of divorces and you
know they they may be initiating it but
for me the way I see it is
these men and these boys
have not been trained enough because
like you said the emphasis is always on
the girls the girls the girls and never
so much on the boys the boys are getting
away with murder they're getting away
with God knows what you know you you see
a lot of girls who are well behaved
they're at home you know they're not as
bad as people make out but then you have
the boys out here in the streets smoking
weed having girlfriends uh you know just
running Riot not listening to their
parents
but there's not been enough like
actually what is going on here boys are
really getting away with a lot out here
to be honest with you and for me the way
I see it a kingdom and a nations are led
by men
so if a kingdom and a nation Falls you
can't now put the blame on women you
have to put the blame on the men who are
supposed to lead us who are supposed to
you know bring that Nation up it's not
the fault of women women okay we we do
have to do our part we have to be you
know modest and we have to try as well
but this Dean is a naseeha to us all
it's not just for women
okay
where'd you guys think this is like
stemming from like I want to know that
to me I think like for example one of
the reasons that I was reading some
tafsir one of the reasons that the
correlation the Pagan Arabs used to bury
their daughters alive uh there's a
couple of reasons one of the reasons was
because they um said okay you know they
can't provide for them yeah another
reason was is this uh phenomena which is
basically that if they both wore the
female relatives will be taken of
captives and
um you guys get the gist yeah so they
felt that as this is disgraceful to us
so therefore it's it's I think this is
where it stems from because if you look
at it we talk about this issue yeah
um and we've mentioned this before
dinner is dinner for a man or a woman
adulterers adult treatment for a man or
a woman a woman the punishment in the
Hereafter is the same however which I do
agree that there are the concept
consequent for example and I'm just
mentioning these examples without being
too crude is that
if you get into a fight in school like
we've gone to school yeah you usually if
you're having a fight with another man
what is the first thing that he's he
could say to you to make your blood boil
answer to your mom okay good this is
very interesting because we really need
to understand this in deep here because
straightforward your mom your sister
your daughter why
comparison good so this is what I mean
by
in general in our day-to-day lives this
is a reality why because it stems to
again and I talk about these issues and
this one the reason I started the truth
show is so our sisters can understand
and also we can understand as well is
that the acts of
um just so we understand clearly because
it's been done too
forgive me because of that it's they see
as something degrading now I understand
that but again again I really don't want
to make this show about it's the sisters
because I'm really passionate about this
in the sense where and I was on a recent
podcast with one sister and I don't
blame her like you know I understand
where she was coming from but she gave a
bit of emphasis on like you know we need
to make sure our daughters and I was
like why
why are those why can't you see our sons
why do General uh
I do agree partially with both of you
but I would like to emphasis about what
you you began to say about
uh Xena is the same for male and females
and I think the root of the problem is
the lack of Islamic knowledge and is
it's more uh than a gender problem it's
a social a social problem that you can
find in many societies Mediterranean
Mediterranean Oriental societies and
Islam came to get rid of those
preconceptions who are which are fools
it's in our innate nature I agree with
you that uh something the most trigger
in software offense you can do to
someone to go for his female of his
household
but
our legislation is what Allah sent and
the the role is the same when Allah said
to the the believing man to lower the
Gaze he said it uh also for the the
believing women and uh we have the
tendency to to forget that uh the the
the the doubt of the the males are from
the the knees and the brother uh like to
show off they go to the gym they get
booked and uh they uh forgot that uh
that was the topic of the first place
that the Mother's Day modesty is uh
something who which is a mandatory for
them as well as well but I agree that
socially the you can bring more fitna if
uh because uh for basic reason biology
for the the the the the bodies of the
physical gender is not that uh making
that or um sorry as to my English is not
my first normal second language but he
um I do agree with you but I I just
wanted to emphasize that the deep root
of the problem was the lack of Islamic
knowledge Allah
yeah that was a really good point I just
want to add to that
um just to kind of go back to the
jahidia time
um and also uh post Islam time and when
we think about the social construct and
the definition of the meaning of Honor
that that made changes through different
times so in the times of
the woman was seen as inferior so the
idea was this inferior being is
therefore an embarrassment so can't do
whatever it was the men were doing at
the time so based off that that that's
kind of how it started where you know
it's an embarrassment to have uh these
you know humans around
in the time of Islam when Islam came
Islam came with honor for women so that
will uh definition that's where that's
when it started so the sense of Honor on
women is when Islam arrived now over the
course of time closer history
um Islam in its purest form obviously
has mixed with culture so where you've
had different cultures within the Uma
with all their own ideas trying to adapt
to Islam some perhaps more you know and
this is one's opinion some more
successory than others in terms of
separating Islam culture
the women under different cultures that
definition of Honor has been placed on
women through using Islam but at the
same time uh Define defying Islam by
actually only putting the honor on women
like we've already established honor
comes from men and women we all we all
have to be modest we all have to you
know we all have the same rules there's
not one rule for men and one Wolf Woman
With regards to modesty and that entails
uh behavioral dress like brother just
mentioned Etc so I think it's just
there's been too much emphasis placed on
women modesty and I think that is also
stem from the fact that the biggest
difference in modesty between men and
women is the hijab physically so that's
kind of where the starting point is
because it's something that we can see
and it's something that's obvious
honor is applied differently to men and
women
um I'd say for women honors apply to
their looks because it comes down to
Beauty
um so the original question the original
topic is Modesty why is it applied more
to women it's simply because
honor and modesty is something that
women should Prosper to do more because
it's what we look at whereas for men
we're not as for lack of better words
we're not as beautiful so if I was to
walk out into the street and I see a
bunch of people and I look over to them
and I think they're nice I might not
believe I might not say so because
um
sometimes I have an issue when I speak
you know I used to get that you know
what I would say is um do you do it you
know money even a car I'll give it to
you basically do it because the thing is
I used to get actually I can remember in
I was I went to one University talk I
literally I I was in the tour there was
a university off topic I literally froze
exactly what I went for my life my mind
went blank and I was just I didn't know
what to say it's it's it's it's happened
to me you know I realized it's um like
make sure you do your morning even as
hard bro
um and it's very important so it happens
normal but not like you know you know if
you let me know when you yeah you know
what it is from when I was younger from
when I was in school and I would speak
out into like the class and whatnot like
presentations right because you were
forced you were forced to do it so
you've got a negative connotation of
talking the last the last two times I
was on the show the last two two
episodes I've done I was fine yes but I
think I think it's because sometimes you
feel the lights on you in that sense but
it's totally normal but my point the
point I really want to get my point yeah
my point across modesty is applied
differently to men and women that's I
think I believe that is the answer
um for for women it's looks and I think
if I'm talking about honor with men it's
to do more with how you handle your
business more to do with handle your
yourself with other men whether it's
physicality uh financially that's our
honor is determined with men whereas
with women it's more of their looks it's
people can I just can I make a point on
that sorry yeah so in Islam
modesty hijab is not just looks
modesty is your tongue yeah you speak
your heart
the way you act your character so it's
an umbrella it's not just Beauty because
a lot of women you know you would say
some women are beautiful yes but a lot
of women are average like we're just
human beings you know not not to our
sister Mira when it comes to when it
comes it's just just I want to cut you
because it's very important because this
is where the the misunderstanding
happens we don't think like you do it's
very important for us to understand yeah
just just so you know for a brother like
I was speaking to a Saudi sister and I
was saying that some brothers who get
excited over uncle and you start
laughing and and there was Brothers in
the crowd they were like sure yeah and
she was shocked she was like really I
was like yes no this is how we are
created the thing is that's why women
like to be seen and men like to see
that's what we're talking to Laura gives
and woman told to cover up we should
also cover up Israel and they are trying
to lower the Gaze as well but in the
priorities just just because of that you
need to understand you might think it's
just average trust me a average woman
could get multiple DMS left right center
and this is dealing like they do some
studies yeah uh women get hundreds of
messages you go to a problem who's
average and ask him if he's got one
message in his life
but your point is about modest thing is
Modesty is an umbrella term it's not
just about the beauty it's about about
the character that's why when you say
honor is applied to women differently it
shouldn't be placed on women differently
like the sister said here you know
of course the hijab is something
physical that people can see because
women can Muslim women can identify as
being Muslim by where in the hijab
however that emphasis and that uh you
know that that emphasis on modesty
should be placed equally onto men as it
is placed onto us as women because even
though we we may apply and you know
where the hijab you hear it all the time
some women wear hijab but actually
they're they're the biggest backbiters
or they do this so hijab has to be taken
care of on all aspects not just the
physical because that's where you have
some people who are called Hypocrites
you know and we have a lot of men
unfortunately who are
Hypocrites because they take care of one
thing but they neglect all the other
things that they're supposed to be taken
care of and I do think
as the ummah I'm sorry in this day and
age we're getting weaker and weaker not
not the unmare itself but the men are
getting weaker and weaker they're no
longer a strong or disciplined as
they're supposed to be you have boys
vaping left right and centered they buy
more Vapes than they do sadaqa or zakats
that is wrong can I make a point between
we hope to another subject because uh
the the point the sister and the brother
made
um was maybe the root of the problem we
hopped from honor to modesty and just
before we talk about shame and maybe the
the problem is semantic what is honor
what is a modesty can you define it
because uh I can this topic reminds me
um an advice that a Palestinian brother
told me to to raise my children you say
one advice I will give you my brother is
never say this is shameful this is not
wrong this is not honorable say this is
halal raise your children like that
because I grew up in Palestine I came
here and I traveled to Germany and in
every society what is shameful could be
normal and could be illegal to another
and we have our legislation what is the
which are the Quran Sunnah and maybe we
should focus on modesty itself as our
decreted it and honor and shame maybe
should be left yeah we have our own
objective principles and morality yeah
would you say we're different would you
say men and women are different
absolutely yeah so don't you believe
that not don't you believe don't you
think that
it should be applied differently if we
are different or do you think it should
be the same applied the same well it is
the same in Islam is the same modesty
has to be the same it has to be applied
the same again yeah it's only different
for a woman when it comes to the
physical appearance where we have to be
more modest in that aspect but men also
neglect like the brother said that that
modesty you see a lot of Muslim men
showing that umbilical their belly
button all the way to their knees or
whatever the case may be that's a
modesty that is neglected now it should
be applied
the same and equally the emphasis I'm
talking about the emphasis because
that's what Ali said the emphasis has to
be the same because the punishment is
the same
in the grave it's no different
that is you know you may feel
differently because you're a man which
is fine and the way you honor your
sister or honor your mother or the way
you want her to be out of here in the
streets might be different of course you
have more of that that jealousy over
your your wife but when you have two
kids a boy and a girl you have to treat
them the same and raise them equally so
they both have the same principles and
morality when they leave your home and
go out and conduct themselves out in the
in the public yeah I disagree with that
because I think we don't live I mean I
agree with what you've always said but
we don't live in a perfect world and as
much as we want it to be balanced I
don't see ever being balanced so to make
sure moving forward if you do have
daughters to protect them you do have to
focus on them a little bit more in a way
of right you're going to protect
yourself because she could become a
strong independent woman there's no
doubt in that but once she's out there
she is vulnerable because and we can't
ignore that we can't Overlook that
because we can't say well you raised
them equally therefore they're gonna be
fine once they're out there because men
unfortunately are going to have their
struggles and I think if we don't
protect our daughters in a way where we
emphasize protection whether it's
modesty or honor you know whatever it
may be
um they're more likely to suffer the
consequences once they are out there and
I think the way that we're going right
now we're heading to an environment a
place in world where women are hyper
independent where they will go they will
travel abroad they will you know live by
themselves
they are still vulnerable and I think
that's as a parent myself I would I
wouldn't raise them the same I I
wouldn't yeah emphasize on my daughter a
lot more than I would of my son but when
I say emphasize I'm not going to say
right son it's okay for you to be out
till 10. daughter no home at night don't
even think about it not like that in a
way where the way that I I tailor the
upbringing to her is going to be very
different and it's gonna be very
different for the sun I'm still
emphasizing on both but I'm I'm using
very different strategies to help them
sort of you know be out there as safe
and sound so if I understood this
correctly I think what you're saying is
very valid in the sense where
agree and disagree in the sense way well
actually not agree because you're seeing
the reality is that of course there
should be higher for both and we do
acknowledge what you said Michael which
is that of course they're different as
well but you're saying that because I
mean realistically we would want it to
be where that's the case but because we
live in an environment we're in the west
and in the west it's we know how it is
sadly so you're seeing because of the
threats out there I have to emphasize on
my daughters more not because because
you know Islam says basically modesty is
modestly you get it we need to
understand that when it comes to Aura a
man showing his knee even if it's this
much yeah this is what we need to
understand when it comes to our religion
it's very profound
and sorry to give these examples but if
a man is showing arguments
whatever you define this Allah just
because this is not like arguments it's
not a fitness for a sister irrelevant
that's an hour an hour is an hour it
doesn't matter it's if a woman is you
know dressed up in that manner so I
think you're seeing because the threat
is greater for the Sisters that's what
his emphasis is true but let's come back
to a point I'm going to go to the sister
inshallah is again
I believe genuinely yeah we should
of course we should advise our doses Etc
but are we doing anything for our sons I
genuinely believe I don't think we're
doing anything like I feel like I might
be wrong who but do we get Muslim father
sitting down and seen listen if you come
across a woman
she doesn't respect herself
you respect her or I don't see it that's
my point of this discussion I don't see
the great emphasis I know every single
sister has definitely been sat in front
of a brother or a father and be like
listen
yeah I think uh to piggyback on that
everything stems from childhood right so
in the manner that we raise our boys in
comparison to the way that we raise our
girls right so for those of us that will
raise in households where we had
Brothers we know that we were taught the
importance of wearing our hijab in
comparison to our brothers they went to
that same emphasis wasn't put on them
right so for instance you see sometimes
some mothers or fathers walking out with
their children and the daughter is
covered from head to toe in Abaya and
you know and hijab and the boys wearing
shorts and he's wearing vests and he's
you know he's doing he's wearing
whatever he wants to wear you know and
that is not uh in accordance to the
teachings and the laws of Islam we know
that right so and like the brother said
earlier different cultures Define on it
differently right but one thing we can
all agree with is that honor you know
majority of the times is placed on the
woman so the owner of the family uh you
know most of the times is dependent or
contingent upon the way that the woman
acts right so the way that the woman is
so if the woman is dishonorable say for
instance she does things that may
dishonor herself now instantly
um you know this family is deemed to be
a dishonorable family she's tarnished
the reputation of the family this is why
only killings exist right if the woman
does something that you know displeases
her father or the male relatives in her
family they you know they they resort to
unfortunately taking her life right so
this is something that exists so
everything stems from childhood this
notion of boys will be boys men will be
men let him do you know what he plays
like I remember growing up being raised
with this idea that a man has no shame
you know a man he can do as he pleases
ultimately this shame will fall on his
female relatives right whereas a woman
right it's entirely different
you know she doesn't have um that same
level of Grace isn't given to her right
so even say for instance the woman is a
good sister you know she's uh she's
practicing Islam but she's not wearing
hijab she's instantly deemed to be
dishonorable whereas the brother he
could be a drug dealer he could be
whatever he could be incarcerated but
that same level of you know the emphasis
of you know he's a dishonorable person
but this and that is not placed upon
this system for him the brother
unfortunately can I can I just add to
that because you talk um just oh
what you just said
um I think to be frank and if we're
honest the honor on the what the reason
why we've put the responsibility of
Honor on the female is to do with
virginity and that's kind of where it
started and no one questions males with
regards to that you know aspect of
things and that's not a topic of
discussion when sisters come to get
married I mean I'm talking about certain
cultures or back in the day doesn't
happen in every culture but that's
actually where it started from so
someone that was never married was
expected obviously as per Islam anyway
to you know be a virgin if you were
divorced that obviously we all know that
that wouldn't be the case necessarily so
the honor starts off from there so
there's a price and the price was put on
that so you know I you know someone
would come want to marry someone's
daughter I have three daughters who have
all been who are all unmarried so you
have you know those girls are carrying
the honor of the family on that basis of
of you know them being moral or immoral
and it's to do with that and sister
Amira mentioned um earlier about red
pill and that's why red pill goes on
about you know body counts and and you
know women you know and you know
whatever they're doing and that kind of
value and that is where it stems from
um also not to conflate in my opinion
honor with Majesty because you can have
uh someone that appears to be modest
like Sister Mary said that's really
dishonorable and vice versa
um also I do agree with sister Ira to an
extent in the sense where you we've got
to equip our children with different
skill sets skill sets based on their
gender to survive in society
um the risks are different for girls
they're now for boys
um yes sometimes modest dress or
immodest stress can be a form of
creating risk for yourself or Immortal
stress in a sense but I don't entirely
agree with that because there are hijabi
sisters that have been attacked most
recently there was a case of a hijabi
sister not long ago a few weeks ago that
was you know attacked
um by a male
um in London and you know how do you
kind of Define I wasn't talking about
dress sense okay it was how we raised
them mentally to survive not necessarily
to survive I guess yeah to survive
that's what we're trying to do in these
Earth anyways but it's like when you go
out there yeah how to protect yourself
how to be cautious yeah you know and
like red flags and you know because they
are vulnerable nobody can Overlook that
yeah so I think yeah I think a culture
plays a big role in this I think once
again culture is the issue because it's
like as you said like on honor killings
that happens even in my culture that
happens regardless of where it is in the
world but I think um naturally because a
woman has more to lose
um and you know a small little rumor
could destroy her in an entire future
yeah that's true why mothers especially
focus more on right you know you can't
go out and it's like they imprison them
almost and when it comes to the sun
mothers are more lenient than the
fathers are which is sure
sorry sorry let me just say something in
regards to women we are really brought
up as these weak fragile things like
Damsel in Distress I'll be honest I was
raised quite tough my my dad never
allowed me to be a victim in this world
he obviously taught me that you know you
have to be strong be aware don't walk
down the alleyway you've got to be
shrinked smart as well at the same time
but when it comes to the to the thing of
raising your kids if I'm raising my if I
had a son if Allah blessed me with my
son I'm raising that my daughter just as
tough as I'm raising my son because at
the end of the day they're not gonna
they're not gonna go out in the world
with two separate no it is the same
thing morals principles character builds
a human being so if you're if you're
disciplined and you teach your kids to
be disciplined in China do you think
they're teaching the girls and boys to
be completely different they're they're
raising soldiers in China right now
whilst here where where literally we
don't know if this one's a man or or a
woman or we don't know what we're too
weak we're not disciplined and then you
have this red pill
um ideology and a lot of our Muslim
brothers and younger youth who are
following this red pill ideology yeah
they're following a degeneracy with the
red pill ideology
degenerate holding myself for too long
because I wanted to make
oh is it from someone else
no no I disagree with the the hopping
from the subject to another okay because
I think that the root of the problem
mother said and the sister gave her
another a very good explanation about uh
honor killing you described straight up
and Islam came exactly for to to fight
all those nonsense and I think that the
root of the problem is is not the the
red pill or the gender or the education
is our lack of Islamic knowledge if we
want something else go get another
religion our religion is Islam or
legislation and if if you want to
understand why we don't have the the
same balance uh be in our education of
the youth when regarding to the the
modesty is because we didn't understand
our Dean yeah that's that's yeah in a
nutshell yeah
sorry for the foreign about
um letting boys be boys and men be men
if you let boys be boys a lot of the
time they just revert how they feel like
like you're more animalistic like the
reptile side of your brain if you just
let us boys be boys they just do however
they feel them and so especially in our
like especially in my culture like
growing up and growing up in England
like because religion's kind of been
forgotten here it's more so just you can
just go on based on how you feel and
that goes for girls as well I mean
that's very evident if if you look at
Society if you look at social media
that's why I find Islam so important and
that's why I picked Islam because I'm
personally not a tolerant person and I
feel like if you if you stand for if you
stand for not that if what is it
there you go there you go so that's why
I was that's why I was learning better
than I just thought I actually believe I
believe this and so I went to the mosque
in Britain and I reverted and I became
Muslim and I think if everyone I think a
anyone needs to read the Quran and think
they only need to read it and they'll
know the right way to live and that goes
for man or woman and I think after
listening to the sisters you're
definitely right when it comes to when
it comes to modesty on both when it
comes to covering yourself it both the
only thing I would disagree with though
is the the problems both men and women
are going to face
um I can't talk I can't talk on what
women are going to face I'm a woman
um
but for men I can definitely say that
there are things that men will face that
women want and women will face that men
want and I think it's I genuinely and I
think we can argue back and forth on
this all day yeah that I genuinely
believe that men and women should be
taught slightly different things as
they're growing up to to
um to conquer different battles that
they're going to face in life yeah
that's it I agree I will also add that
thing it's not just about covering
yourself it's how do you beat you behave
how you walk
yes yeah this is brought down to um just
your clothing
um and you know that's not just it but a
few things that for example when it
comes to honor killing this is a totally
against Islam this concept of Honor
killing like what lights is it's
actually it's it's crazy like the fact
that people describe this Islam you know
Islam is totally against it man there is
there is there is nothing that this
concept of if your daughter goes and
gets a boyfriend or argument you found
that she committed Xin or that you kill
her there's no text in Islam even
anywhere
yeah some parents get so angry they end
up killing their child yes that happened
and this didn't go didn't it yeah it did
there was a Kurdish uh yeah she
literally they they cut her body up and
put it like literally and this was
because she was getting to know someone
or something along those lines and
people connected to Islam it's got
nothing to do with Islam nowhere in
Islam the Quran tells you that and not
only that it tells you the opposite that
if this happens you need to hide it
there is some narration that was where a
old man came and said um
you should hide it and uh forget that
role like for example the
responsibilities like of course I
believe the intimacy The Gatekeepers of
intimacy are women
I believe that that's 100 the case but
yes that that that is the case and
that's why for example when it comes to
this issue one of the seven major sins
on the Hadith for the process is the one
who Slanders a chaste woman yeah it's
100 that's a 180 lashes 80 lashes yeah
unless you go to the woman that you
stand it and she forgives you but it's
18 lashes and your testimony from that
deal is rejected why because the honor
of a woman is so cold in his team in
Islam and and yeah so that's why it
gives that emphasis so can we understand
maybe from this Hadith that there is
that responsibility is it stemming from
that I don't know because I don't think
yes that shows the responsibility is
there but it doesn't mean necessarily
that you should emphasize on that
because I think we should
educate our young men and I've mentioned
this story like this story before I
mentioned again and I'll be mentioned in
my marriage documentary as well and I go
into detail about this because when I
first came to Islam like I lived in
Chinese I've been partying all this kind
of nonsense here and I repented and I
came alhamdulillah and to me is that
when I came like I just said Allah I'm
never ever touching a woman ever again
like just the whole thing just I was
like hollas and to my amazement like to
me I was like when I came to Sam and I
saw sisters in hijabi I was like wow I
would want to have a wife like that one
day you know but I would I didn't have
any Muslim uh friends I didn't know so I
was on these these websites you know
these Muslim yeah yeah I'll give her
inside actually actually we actually
undercovered some of them in the
documentary we'll find out later uh no
actually we do we actually got full out
Undercover on them and expose what is
this dating or is this what the hell is
this so I would go in there and I would
meet sisters for marriage but it's bear
in mind I was a new Muslim I didn't know
better I didn't know all this whole
worldly thing I was just thinking you
know what my intentions are this and
while I'm telling you I'm telling you
bro the things that I saw I was shocked
about my chin dropped like on the floor
like it was unbelievable what they were
calling to it was unbelievable the way
they were operating and I don't want to
get into details but to me as a Muslim
man I had to know better bro I couldn't
be like oh she's moving like this so in
Japanese that's how Brothers move did
you get it she's moving like that yeah
but you treat her like that okay I just
I don't follow this Japanese anymore I
follow Islam and Islam it tells me I do
not care if she's there telling me out
right let's go and do this the hell with
you man get the hell away from me you
yeah if you're moving like that salaam
alaikum I I got nothing to do with that
I'm not gonna say oh I lie yeah we've
been interested it was her fault no man
you've done it both for you did it so I
have to know better so do we train do we
educate our sons like I don't have sons
I got three daughters I'm the lawyer
and to me if I had the son I would have
to like for example I would have to show
my son a the hardship of life because
he's got a lot of responsibilities on
the shoulder so you know I would say
that I speak to my wife sometimes and I
go yeah when these two years are going
to stop jabbing these ribs I'm going to
call the nspcc
so the thing is here is that I'm like
because as a mother she doesn't
understand but to me it's like I'm
trying to bring him to the world where
these things are going to happen you get
it but I would want to sit down with my
son and say listen I know for for us I
know the fact that level yeah
may Allah uh help the brothers who are
single the point here is this irrelevant
to the point I do not care if the
brother is dying yeah there is methods
in the Quran we can use yeah get married
but the point is now when I will never
ever tell my son like yeah you know you
keep your friends
what is this you hear this vote on life
you hear Muslim fathers telling their
sons yeah you go are you linked well
like I'm gonna go see my girlfriend
that's my boy once once again the
problem but that's what I'm saying so I
do not know where it's stemming from but
can we talk about how as men and mothers
as well how should we nurture our sons I
really want to know because the people
that are watching out there if you start
this at home of yeah my son you go
what the hell is this so how do we just
move into that solutions to do drugs
it's better for me than than you know I
don't know
about the drugs I think but and and also
and also you know I find really funny
about the red pill they're very funny
they complain about yeah women with
their body cars body counts and they are
the ones
yeah
it's so dumb yeah you make sure the
woman is not untouched yet is that bro
what are you doing yeah see we're 15
women yeah so bro are you dumb like
you're literally you're cutting your and
I see Mr Brothers if you start moving
like that well let me tell you something
you see when you go and try to and I'm
not blaming I'm not trying to make the
system totally innocent let's be real
here I'm so sorry yeah these days
sisters are on another level Bob I see
Brothers got more High outside there but
the point is this I'm just saying that
in a nutshell we should like
I just happened once and I forgot what I
was saying I thought it was kind of red
pill I can even remember but in a
nutshell the point what I'm saying is
that
how do we nurture our sons like for
example for those who are watching this
parents are watching this how do we
nurture our sons how they should be
towards the opposite agenda and if I
remember when I'll come back
so firstly I just want to say in in
regards to Sons
um
you can do whatever you want to do to to
teach your children I think it's
important to
instill Islamic Studies and still uh you
know madrasa learning Quran you know
taking them around men who are
inspirational you know because right now
there is a lack of inspiration and
obviously we have the best inspiration
which is the prophet Muhammad
but even the prophet Muhammad sallam had
a sahaba good friends you know there's
there's a lack of inspiration and good
quality people for these young boys to
look up to so they need to be around men
and this is why a lot of Muslim boys are
sticking to this red pill ideology I
promise you Islam teaches you ultimate
discipline control you can be successful
you can be a masculine man without the
red pill Islam teaches you all of those
things you do not need to go to that red
pool red pill is full of degenerate men
degenerate men they are the lowest of
the lowest of men they sit on their
computers they type they insult women
they dishonor women they are not
masculine men Muslim men who follow the
Islam the Sunnah The Deen properly they
are masculine men bring your sons to
Islam teach them discipline put them in
kickboxing put them in archery whatever
take them into something that's going to
teach them ultimate discipline and Islam
is the number one thing to start that's
why I really agree with with the brother
here because you know we have everything
in the Sunnah we have everything that
enables us to stay away from societal
poisons
yeah and for me I think we've we're too
weak on our songs we we are we're
forgetting that it takes a village The
Neighbors in Africa and back in the day
could slap your son of course if he's
being disrespectful to a woman or doing
Badness in the street they will slap you
until they take you back to your parents
then you'll go back to your parents and
your parents yeah and then your parents
will deal with you as well now nowadays
or the dad is too scared to even say
something to their son
what's this
where's the discipline where's the
respect for the parents
so I think it comes down to discipline
it comes down to what the foundations
what we're teaching our sons if you've
got a little boy now it's the time now
to start really can I share a business
excuse me of my personal experience
because I was married as a uh at 19
years old I'm Handler father of three
and during my uh
journey and maybe I was a my first year
of marriage somebody very wise told me a
a very good advice
she told me that if your body is such a
tall being Moroccan
if your body is such a cheap merchandise
that you can't do xenapps so do it
and it really made me so deep
subhanallah
I oh I will at the time hating jinaba
because it was wonders of Allah and I I
saw it Allah but this particular advice
I don't know why resonate with me
subhanallah if you are ready to to
engage in such filthyisms
called Fisk something very uh I don't
know who's uh
okay so it's very very filthy yeah and
um engage in those fields and being okay
with it it's the root of the problem as
well I think
can I just add just um yeah I agree with
what you just said but also just to
continue from sister and mirror
um it's also the issue you know
obviously Islam has taught us everything
and everything we need in a Dunya but
it's also we've also got the societal oh
sorry the cultural norms and the
enabling culture in certain cultures so
for example you know because you know
someone can have a son and a daughter or
a son and daughter's
um and the son has a different set of
rules so for example
um you know the the parents or the you
know the mum won't bat an eyelid over
the son having a girlfriend for example
but with the daughters that's like
something they can't even you know
entertain in their mind
um because of the culture and the honor
aspect of things so it's that enabling
culture
um and I have seen this in you know many
muslim-based cultures but in especially
in my own as well where it's all right
for the boys and people talk about it
openly oh yeah my son he's got his
girlfriend I'm not really happy about
you know her she's from whatever
whatever but and they just talk about it
casually so there's even casual chat
between the mothers so as mothers and as
a mother myself we have a responsibility
to educate our children and that is
actually our position in Islam that's
our you know what what we're supposed to
do as mothers is to educate our children
and straight to give them the moral code
but when you've got you know other
mothers having a casual discussion about
their sons having had x amount of
girlfriends or bringing around the house
then you kind of you're just normalizing
it and
um you know when this normalization
seeps through it's going to affect your
Dean because you're not going to
associate it with you're not going to
think about the dean you're just
thinking about it as gender-based so oh
it's because he's a man we know what men
are like and therefore it's justifiable
because that's a man's nature whereas
it's not a woman's nature to you know
feel have feelings for a man or be open
um you know about someone that she's
interested in because you know she she
should have more control over herself
than him and and I think believable man
well that's unbelievable it's like we
treat women like they're aliens like
they're these beings where you just
program them and go yeah what are you
talking about the woman a woman has
everywhere well I would love if my
daughter came and said Bubba I saw this
um prophet in uni can you come and speak
to him all day every day what like what
we're gonna be like ah you have no Haya
what kind of nonsense is this actually
well I I find it so bizarre and it's a
lack of like you said Islam our Deen
does not teach this bro this is far from
Islam and I talk about this people have
turned Islam as if it's their dad's
religion like it has to be this way or
that way while light is that even the
fact that like she proposed to the
person what are you going to say about
that she has no Haya something are you
talking about she saw a decent honorable
the best man to walk this Earth and she
did and sometimes that sisters come like
under the Speaker's Corner some
assistance come for advice oh there's a
brother I like but I'm scared to
approach I'm like why
what is the problem I want my daughter
is to get married they should be
comfortable enough to me and say and
this is what happens when you make the
Halal Haram you open the doors
literally yes and secrecy was better she
goes and does it behind your back God no
problem well why even if it means you've
got nowhere to stay I don't care my
concern is to please Allah
you can stay here he can stay there no
problem yeah facilitating the Halal
imagine in the sight of Allah you enable
that even if they're at Uni no problem
if that's the case he's a good boy
obviously I'm obviously a man's going to
grill him a bit still yeah
give him some voltages so we know his
lungs can open up here yeah
um you're gonna do that after you've
done that it's like okay I want to cater
for this out I want it to be Halal you
get it but most these days sisters are
alive and like feeling as if I've got no
one to talk to and this is the reason
why they get taken advantage of his
world so again we're talking about honor
but we or maybe as men blameworthy
sometimes that our Duties are going and
falling into Haram because we've made
the Halal Haram so it's actually on
about your your pushing away you're not
like the red pill yeah it's a Jeep but
yeah guys we've got good about 10-15
minutes but
um it's still again as men can we talk
about you you've got how many kids
you've got three kids or girls no no one
girl and two boys okay how old is he the
my daughter is the the all those is six
years ago Okay Marshall when would you
think like you would have a discussion
where you see him in front of you and be
like you know what this is when do you
think about it as a father what would
you say to your father start watching
this how how should that discussion be
um yeah first and foremost if you have a
good memory remember yourself
we have the interest of something even
if we are not concerned about it even
before puberty so don't be candid and
naive and think that the today's with
the internet everything is available so
in the can I I won't say the
kindergarten but in middle school or
Primary School uh things happen so if
you don't teach yourself your children
some important stuff people someone else
would and unfortunately most of the time
it would be in a very bad way so I will
inshallah try to talk to him even to my
daughter or not only today let's pick
the sounds what what would you say to
your son that let's let's speak to your
son you spend 16 or 15 or whatever like
the the sister said I will mainly focus
on his Islamic education
this will facilitate things you see I
will sit with him and say you know son
now you're growing up and now this is
gonna going to happen but remember this
is Haram this is why you don't but you
can't do it the Halloween way something
that
kills me is that people can
um consider Haram we make we met yes and
I was married at the University I have
made long series I I have went through
medical studies so for 10 years I was a
student and married in the in my uh in
the uni I was called the married guy and
mashallah
many of my friends come how do you how
could you do that
do what to be married so such uh such a
there you go you know I guess you
sorry do you have a girlfriend say yes
how could you do that and the wrong
Muslim this do you see the point now did
you know what they're doing this scene
is weird you know what I see this man
come to me and go brother how would you
oh I'm 32. have you been married before
he says no now obviously I have to
assume the best but in my head I'm
thinking how the hell is a 31 year old
man
what the hell like why are you taking
some drugs
no I want to know what lies said very
simple if a man is not married
yeah and you know he's he's not fasting
yeah there's a few things that's coming
up with simple conclusions
it's very simple how are you surviving
for 30 years up to the age of 30 and
you're not married brother there's
something going on and most of them are
speak bro there's always that yeah there
was a relationship uh three years
relationship uh Etc I remembered my
point I forgot which was uh very
profound as well yeah these men who go
around and sleep around just know my
brother
listen to me carefully yeah I've come
from here I've seen I know my friends
when you go and mess around with these
girls just know that there is another
man out there just like you doing it to
your sister now repeat again when you or
your daughter when you go around and
think yeah I'm having fun left right
center and these women are to blame as
well but just know my brother
that's another man is probably doing
just like you don't think this is you
don't think it's just me I'm the only
one nope you're doing that brother just
know there's somebody else will be doing
that to your future wife and when the
day comes and you're marrying and you're
like why did that happen because she
came across a man like you
just know it so don't cry about it don't
rip your head you can Bang Your Head On
The Wall if you want I think you should
you know actually pass out
um you could call the ambulance
inshallah but the point is this when you
violate Allah's laws and think as if
there's no consequences you know a lot
of time people put as if Allah can't
hear them yeah man's gonna be a fine
exception I Repent as if can you imagine
it's an Akita issue bro well like can
you imagine you are literally plotting
against Allah I'm gonna do yeah I'm
gonna go sleep around with this dumb red
pill movement of 50 women
do you think Allah doesn't hear you
Allah is prostitute in your juggling
Allah knows what's going through your
head you know and that's what Allah says
in in Quran specific verse Allah says we
send them signs and then we send them
signs again until they persist Allah
says we open the doors
it's very scary bro Allah is basically
saying you know when you keep persistent
persisting and persistent Allah sends
you signs and signs and signs and you
carrying Allah says we open the doors
meaning the doors of the Haram that you
want Allah opens the doors you know
Allah says in the end of that verse
and when they think they've reached
their peace and Untouchable we snatch
their soul
can you imagine in that moment where
you're thinking yeah I've got the girls
and this that and you're in the club and
the heart stops and that is how you're
going to be Resurrected
so yeah any last words
but please uh I I agree with what you
said and the last part mashallah but um
I strongly disagree with this notion
that a woman will have to bear the
consequences of the man's wrongdoings or
bad actions right this is not an Islamic
uh uh you know this this is not based on
the teachings of Islam this is merely
coming from culture this idea that if
your brother goes around being a
degenerate right one day you you
yourself will face it the general when
you haven't done nothing right so we
know that this does not derive from
Islamic ideology it's not it's not
derived from Islamic teachings right but
it comes from toxic culture this idea
that a man can never be held accountable
no matter what he does he will never
bear the consequences of his bad doing
of his bad actions and his wrongdoings
and that the female relatives will
always always have to pay for his
wrongdoings and that's something I
disagree with strongly I just want to
clarify if you came across like that I
was not saying that's but I'm not saying
that for example if you do it that it's
going to there's nowhere in the Quran
that I know that says that if you do a
it will come actually in the Quran or
Hadith says that nobody Bears the sin of
someone else so I'm sorry if it came
across like that so what it means is
when someone has a if somebody's doing
certain action there's Ripple effects on
society it's corruption Allah says
there's corruption is spread in the land
so I don't mean in a way where if you do
this therefore it will happen to your uh
um sister or daughter Etc what I'm
saying is that if you're if you as a man
are going and sleeping around you just
know there are other men like you and
imagine there are 10 000 men like you
that means they are and if every one of
them does that to five women one matches
right I think that's fifty thousand GMC
is talking about the consequences so
forgive me if it came and constantly 100
right yeah to finish off my point um
uh I also wanted to quickly say that I
think is important to
um everything starts off in childhood
like I said earlier right it's extremely
important to raise young boys and young
girls in a similar manner right we
understand that of course there are
biological differences there are
differences that we can of course you
know we cannot deny right but it's
important to the same way you're raising
your child your daughter to treat her
body sacred to look at to respect
herself to honor herself right then you
know the importance of being gentle the
importance of being kind loving caring
nurturing is also just as important to
teach your your sons these same
qualities because these are the
qualities that we need as a society this
idea that is only a woman that could you
know that is expected to be the natural
because she's inherently support
apparently born with this now it's a lie
so everything comes on to socialization
I think you know everything comes down
to you know
um Purity culture is or plays a massive
part as well right this idea that you
know a woman should respect himself but
a man can do is he pleases like we
touched on earlier so you know is
important to teach this the thing the
same the same way that you're raising
your little girls is just as important
to raise your young guys as well I I
would like to emphasize what uh the
Brother Ali said I think it was more um
uh an advice than a thing that there is
some Karma there is no karma in Islam
and I would I remember uh one uh sorry
of uh a young sahabi was very young and
went to the prophet Saws and tried to
negotiate the Xena literally yeah
is it that possible and to see a
subhanallah the the methodology and the
education
your mom this is uh something that
resonates with boys and when you tell
you tell them when you mess with someone
else uh sister or daughter someone would
do the same it have an impact even
though there is no rules that if you do
it it will happen but it's a good advice
I think it's maybe that he wanted to say
right yeah
hold on I think we've said a lot about
how to raise our children but we haven't
spoken about actually setting the
example so I think it starts from home
I've seen so many dads or like imams and
they have the hardest time to love the
gays and then you've got the teenage
sons watching them on their teenage
daughter's also seeing it so it's like
you need to start from home be the
example that you want your children to
become like my son's seven years old and
I've got him we have talks about how a
woman should dress and what is modest
and what it isn't because I know these
are the years where he's going to be
exposed to so much you know corrupt so
it's like I'm doing my best as a single
parent to do that obviously a father has
a different impact but mothers need to
do the same when it comes to the sun
like be the woman that you would want
your son to marry be the father that you
would want your son to grow up to become
I agree
um I think whatever you teach your kids
is likely to be the person they're going
to end up with for the rest of their
life you are what you attract
um so yeah I'd say it's definitely
important to to know what you're
teaching your children because whatever
they whatever they give off in life is
usually what they're going to attract so
yeah any last words anyway
no
I think that's it yeah
okay so I think let's say we're Raphael
brothers and sisters inshallah I hope
you guys have benefited from this and
yeah share it if there's new parents who
have got kids Etc I think it's very
important for us to emphasize uh that
it's not just our daughters have that
responsibility and modesty is not just
clothing uh it's the way you speak the
way you conduct yourself
um and you know look if you think about
there's a Hadith for the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him where he was
sitting down in his uh his his shin was
showing and he covered it when I walked
in and he said that the the even the
angels like you know they are modest
awesome because I can't remember
so you know Savannah and he was someone
that he would even when he's having a
shower he would cover himself because he
knew Allah did you get it that is the
level of modest he had so this is the
man yeah this is a man yeah
how many of us are like that how many of
us when it comes to modesty we even
mentioned that that narration or how he
was this is how he was and this is what
we aspire to be not to the the generate
uh
respiel yeah I don't want to get into so
these individuals who are absolutely
Hypocrites yeah some of them are Muslims
absolutely it makes me sick but the
point is that it's very simple our role
models are not these individuals who are
corrupt individuals who have double
standards and hypocrisy we follow Islam
we follow the best on uh mankind who
walk this Earth which was the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him and his
companions so please please Brothers
understand that and I emphasize and just
because a woman doesn't respect herself
doesn't mean you disrespect her you be
the better person I know well believe me
I know of stories where Brothers have
been the better person and while I well
I'm telling you I've I've heard this
where the sister would message and say
you know what
you know I was in a bad place you knew
better thank you like I was in a bad
place you well lie it can change
somebody and it's like as simple as that
inshallah um yeah until next time from a
bit of Truth
um
the prophet salallahu said whoever
builds a mess
I missed on that day where Allah tells
us that our books will be given and
every little atom weight of Good Deed
you've done will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and you're like what
a lucky person which righteous person
Allah says this is for you for me yes
what did I do
you allowed people to pray you built a
Masjid I never had the money to build a
master to Allah you helped you gave
towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it don't it
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
foreign
[Music]